[Musique]
un rayon de soleil et le moral repart ça
fait beaucoup de bien de sortir un petit
peu et profiter du beau temps
le président lui aussi attendait avec
impatience le retour des beaux jours
avec l'espoir que la hausse des
températures que le vérisme guerre
freine la propagation de l'épidémie
malheureusement ces danseurs à l'âme
légère ne sont pas les seuls à avoir eu
l'idée de profiter du soleil
incroyable allez on va travailler à lons
lâché tout uci team tiamat rennes est
reine le manteau les commerces les
fermer pour les stations de ski de les
faire mais pas
les universités ouvrez-les les
établissements publics culturels
trouverez même
mais ces jeux j'ai entendu ça depuis des
semaines pour ne pas parler des
discothèques
aujourd'hui en province on craint
évidemment l'arrivée massive des
franciliens une internaute annonce un
dans le sud on est complet on a plus de
paix qu il va pleuvoir ce week end n'y
pensez même pas j'aurais aimé vous
m'indiquer monsieur abad et les eaux
comment nous procurer davantage de doses
je vous assure que si vous aviez
formuler une préconisation opérationnel
j'annonçais ici immédiate pas que je
l'adopté
mais rien et rire et à combien le quéau
de l'automate savès possibilité d avoir
pu droite donc pour toute façon ils sont
tous prochain non je dis comme ça c'est
tout est intéressé plutôt décontractée
je sens qu'elle est peu sensible à mon
humour c'est net c'est le râteau fais
moi un sourire magnifique
sortez moi quelque chose de bien sûr
agir je vois accusé patrice laurent le
plateau pour me dire hamid deux
pratiques de misogyne des gens là m'ont
super protégés ils ont même poussé pour
que j'aille plus loin dans mes délires
parce que moi j'étais un peu paris et
tous les tacles est en arrêt pour
remonter dans le temps vous suivez vous
voyez l'évolution c'est eux qui m'ont
donné
l'attaquant argentin du psg a publié
hier sur instagram une photo où on le
voit en compagnie de son chien et de sa
femme wanda et en légende le joueur
écrit mon chien et ma chienne grande
classe il s'est évidemment attiré les
foudres de nombreux internautes
mais la principale intéressée sa femme
wanda ne semble pas particulièrement
fâché elle a simplement commenté en
écrivant quelle élégance accompagné d'un
smiley clin d'oeil qui m'ont blessé et
tmc
parce que ils ont fait une émission je
sais pas si vous l'avez regardé où il
parlait justement du problème de la
femme dans le temps et tout ce qui
s'ensuit et les femmes concernées qui
était encore de ce monde et chérir et
kiabi était sur le plateau et commenter
les images
ben moi m'a jamais prévenu sera pas
demandé mon avis bonjour monde r je suis
julien courbet nous sommes en direct sur
la radio rtl monde r et je suis bien
ryder a cherché à les mondes r oui ces
courbes et de la cei venait d'accrocher
mais non vous accrocherez veto n'est que
j'anticipe et avant même que les gens
ont cru il a dit à son fils qu'il devait
être à côté
ses courbes et alors dire comme si j'ai
appelé tous les jours où on touche pas à
mon pas tout j'étais bien avec eux et là
ils ont chalumeau c'est moi qu'ils ont
fait lui y est ils ont joué sur à cheval
mois mais leafs ont trait à scott dans
la tête on joue pas avec moi on ne vit
pas comme ça
c'est pas possible qu'il vienne
s'éclipse de partout sur le corps ou les
romans et les robots on va leur [ __ ]
leur mère à ses fils de gens méchants
médias dans l'esprit pourquoi depuis des
temps d un peu d les renoir monet à la
loupe
voilà j'ai plongé dans l'après ben ali
bon bah écoute c'est dieu qui donne
cette soirée fiche est une bonne idée
parce que les poissons sont souvent très
heureux mais en france on n'a pas tardé
aussi une soirée qui me va comme un
coming en poussant le cas car c'est une
tarte
[Musique]
m
alors qu'ils viennent ces clubs doivent
tous sur le camp em cible privilégiée
des attrape couillon et jacques bigot
nigauds nigauds nigauds nigauds mini ou
à mon travail en toute hâte en bb c'est
quoi ce délire
mais qu'est ce qui fait passer charlène
bon l'alcool fait des dégâts mais à ce
point là et roman en 2019
chaque français de plus de 15 ans a
ingurgité en moyenne 11,4 litres
d'alcool pur
l'équivalent de 127 bouteilles de vin à
12 degrés c'est presque deux fois plus
que les recommandations des organismes
sanitaires
[Musique]
évidemment tout cela cause des ravages
j'ai pas passer à autre chose assez
sympa pour les mariés qui s'attendent à
un mot de remerciement ou de
félicitations et lui par sur la
politique et à mesure c'est que c'est
toujours le même discours mais c'est pas
toujours les mêmes gens alors ils le
répètent l'alcool rapporte il remporte 3
milliards de taxes mais de l'autre côté
il ya des dépenses et ses dépenses et
7,7 milliards de dépenses pour soigner
les gens qui sont malades des
conséquences de l'alcool voyez ce que
c'est la flotte marchande à potes dans
charles louis c'est l'eau minérale
vendue en bouteille qui
destiné à la consommation et si on va
plus loin
c'est un élément un peu cynique mais le
fait que des gens décèdent avant l'âge
auquel ils toucheraient leur retraite
procure une économie pour l'état de 1,7
milliard quand vous mettez tous ces
chiffres doivent ou en gros l'alcool
coûte 3 milliards d'euros par an aux
finances publiques en appui et peep
cible il ya un tuyau et ça on voit
énormément
[Musique]
est ce que tu veux changer la couche
vas-y si tu veut centrer mais moi je
m'entraîne comme ça je vois que tu as
des zones tu ne griffe pas une boulette
attention ces pressions c'est la relève